Oh
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan Saki and today we are
blessed to have Josh Tetrick on the show
what's up Matt thank you so much for
coming on good to be here it's a
pleasure I love your mind I love where
you came from I love what you're
building into the world thank you Andrew
for helping us get you here and have you
ever been Alabama this one from I have
in there that we gotta take we gotta
take you there little Birmingham
experience yeah baby Mobile yeah did you
get you into like the deep part of the
South every human needs to do a stop in
the south I think every human needs to
stop in Africa stop in Asia just this
whole consciousness expansion across
were you were you from South Dakota
see I haven't done a stop himself
together so we also did some stuff
Dakota do but I agree you can't there's
a lot of great stuff going in Silicon
Valley but the Silicon Valley is not the
world it's not culturally the world it's
not emotionally in the world yeah you
really you have to put your your mind
your feet in the shoes of other people
to really understand what's going on
you're not gonna build things that are
relevant yeah and this has led Josh to
do things like you know work with the UN
and then work with the with Liberia as
well so you've done some work across the
world without and very important and
that kind of led you into this whole
sustainability and food and now just
company you guys have been up for six
and a half years yeah that's amazing
that's a long time to be around and
tinkering with how to feed the world in
a sustainable and healthy safe way yeah
so this six and a half years it's
amazing and now you products are in
stores across the u.s. brother's room
stores across the u.s. we're in about
135,000 points of distribution so you
can find our Mayo in Beckley West
Virginia you can find our cookies at
Texas A&M you can find our dressings at
Whole Foods down the way you can find
just power gauri on the streets of
Monrovia Liberia being sold by an
amazing
naima Ruth on Randall Street I'm sure
you bet on Randall sugar Monrovia before
we are you know that the common
denominator between all the things we do
is food sucks right now we want to make
it better the reason why it's not that
good is because we use tools like
processed sugar conventional animal
protein lots of soy and corn those tools
are not sufficient to build a food
system where people can eat well they're
not sufficient to make this idea of
eating well a basic right which is the
fundamental principle of our company we
need new tools there are a lot of tools
in the plant kingdom some of the animal
kingdom we want to find them use them
make stuff go fast that that more than
anything is the the thing that drives us
I love that mission point it's a human
right to eat healthy eat well that's
really important and think about it to
this I mean think about even the United
States all the things we disagree about
so we disagree whether you know we
should have a ar-15s or not there's some
- scream in the United States there's
some disagreement whether health care
should be a single-payer system or not
there's disagreement whether we should
privatize Social Security there's
disagreement about whether we should
have welfare or not there's disagreement
on prison reform there's disagreement on
all sorts of different things a trump
voter a Bernie Sanders voter a non voter
black white asian doesn't matter
everyone agrees with the basic idea that
it should be easy for human beings to
eat well how could you disagree with
that right and eating well unpacking it
just means at the simplest level food
that tastes really good
is also the same kind of food that's a
little bit better for us that is not
screwing up the planet and that's
available to everyone those all means
yep there's a lot of complexity that
goes into this stuff but at the heart
like everyone should be able to eat well
and I think why I've gotten really
excited about this idea is it's not it's
not a Silicon Valley thing you know it
it works just as nicely with the Trump
voter as a non troppo Terr and I think
there's power and ideas like that and
there's something you know there's
something Universal about the experience
of food food is not artificial
intelligence it's not no code on a
smartphone we've been doing this food
thing for thousands of years we'll do it
for thousands more
and you know it strikes a chord with
people it is not rocket science but it
is very difficult science to put
together what you have done and to be
able to grow food sustainably from the
cell of a stem cell from a chicken turn
that into a whole chicken breast to do
things like put together the ingredient
list here so Mayo normally comes with
egg mm-hmm and normally comes with other
dairy as well every once and again
you'll have a little dairy but primarily
it's a chicken egg chicken egg from
there about one point one trillion
chicken eggs are laid every single year
around the world so cheapest most
abundant source of animal protein vast
majority of the chicken eggs come from
places that most people wouldn't want to
see too much land too much water and
what we did here is to say I bet we can
make a better Mayo which is America's
most popular condiment we can make a
better Mayo it can be healthier has
about 1/3 of the fat can use less land
less water can even be tastier mm-hmm if
we use different ingredients and we used
a yellow split pea from Canada and some
other things in there too to make Mayo
that you know isn't just for the whole
foods crowd although I want them to buy
it but is in every single solitary
Walmart around the country right now
right right in this moment you go to any
anyone who's listening is watching this
you can go to any Walmart anywhere
around the country
you can go past the you know Tyson
chicken nuggets around the cereal next
to the you know next to the the Snickers
and around the you know six-packs of
Coca Cola and beer go to the condiment
aisle and you'll see our Mayo there with
the biggest brands in the world amazing
and that takes a lot of effort it takes
a lot of effort to refine this to a
really good taste and also to get it
into all of those different distribution
outlets now what is expeller pressed
canola oil that's the first ingredient
on it's just a canola so you can make
mayo or dressings with different kinds
of oil and you can make it with canola
oil you can make it with soybean oil you
can
with safflower oil sunflower oil all
kinds of oils ours works better with
with a type of non-gmo expeller pressed
canola oil that we source from Canada
and from cool areas in Asia and it just
gives a there's a certain texture not an
aftertaste that is is not that works and
some of the applications I loved it when
I tried it at World's Fair it was really
good I've really enjoyed it and then you
know you have water and then modified
food starch is distilled vinegar sugar
so the ingredient list is fairly short
about 10 ingredients everything you know
or like have a general idea of and what
we what we love about you know we're not
a Mayo company but we're super proud of
this product that the vast majority of
people that are going into Walmart's and
buying this have no idea what veganism
is they're not vegetarian they're
bringing that home to their family and
they're making chicken salad or egg
salad with it they're throwing it on a
hamburger yeah yeah and we really do
think that the dogma that often exists
of you know you need to be vegan or
vegetarian or you know not it's a it's a
false choice and you know I am uh I like
to think of myself as environmentalists
yet I probably racked up over a hundred
thousand miles over the last two months
you know traveling you know like travel
right and that's a huge yeah I just mean
to say that you know we're the the human
the human animal is an imperfect animal
and we need to figure out ways to
support each other so we can do better
and this is a tiny little step with
something that a lot of people eat that
that hopefully can can be again just a
tiny little step towards helping us
become better and also helping people to
eat a little bit better yep and so that
was the first product line that was
first one and then what came second
because we have some cookies we have
some yeah we have some powder gauri here
we have we have a little breakfast
sandwiches burgers yeah so tell us about
what's in this for you gotta keep in
mind this is this is I had no idea what
the hell I was in when I started the
company so I just knew
food system screwed up I want to use my
life for something meaningful you
started to think about why the food
system is so screwed up and then and
then got started I actually thought
initially we were gonna be an ingredient
company we weren't gonna make products
like powered or in your hand in Mayo and
just scramble in these cookies and one
day I got a call from the the head of
grocery from Whole Foods at the time he
said we've been reading articles about
you guys you seem to be doing some
interesting things you have any products
we could sample mm-hmm
I sent him a few things including Mayo
we had cookies and cookie dough and
other things and he said I'm legging
that Mayo can you send me more samples
some more samples and then shortly
thereafter he said you know what let's
do a national launch national national
boom that's like 5,000 stores hopefully
does many fewer than that they about
they about 400 yeah well Walmart has
about four plus dollars and Whole Foods
has about 450 or so okay and then BOOM
we were in we were in all those
different ways that people could access
yes since then we like to go our kind of
theory of the case here is food system
if you just kind of step back food
system big about four point eight
trillion dollars most of the categories
that make up food include baked goods
north of 300 billion dollars dairy north
of 300 billion dollars meat 1.1 trillion
dollars eggs north of 200 billion
dollars there are big categories that
are growing what about fruit and
vegetable there's a big - yeah those are
we don't mess with them because I want
people to eat more fruits and vegetables
yeah but those are those are big yeah so
we we think is let's look at these big
categories let's ask ourselves what
might be inherently wrong with those big
categories and if you just look at it
many of them use too much land too much
water many of them accelerate obesity
many of them accelerate diabetes many of
them aren't working because of the
existing tools used to make them are the
same old things process sugar
conventional animal protein soy and corn
but if we can use a different set of
tools
maybe tools from the plant kingdom as an
example to build them from scratch well
maybe that can be healthier more
sustainable tastier more accessible yes
so the way we think about is new tools
and let's go after these big categories
and and as you say we got Mayo here we
found a bean a little bit ago that we
threw in a pan and it turns out it
scrambles like a chicken egg so that's
called the mung bean it's called the
mung bean so the mung beans in the world
been in the world's food system for 40
400 years we didn't invent the mung bean
and it turns out that when you put it in
a pan at scrambles you can make
breakfast sandwiches out of it we
launched this product in the Bay Area
it's called just scramble and it's also
in Hong Kong and we're gonna be
launching all across the United States
and all across the world some and we
want like like all of our products we
want the vast majority of people to eat
it not because they care about the
environment not because they care about
hens and cages but because they want
food that tastes really good and then a
nice benefit to that is it makes them
feel good about doing some little bit
better you know but tastes must be the
headline or else wind up building a
company for people that really care
which is building a really small company
this looks I mean this looks just like
egg you know yeah this is a hard one
it's breaking up just like egg yeah and
it tastes really yeah this work this was
one of our hardest probably our hardest
to do I mean imagine imagine like we're
sitting here hmm imagine we're sitting
here six years or so ago when we started
the company and we're like let's find
something some plant that scrambles like
an egg correct that's so typical
where the [ __ ] you start I'm just
imagine like literally we're like the
egg is the cheapest most abundant source
of animal protein he uses a lot of land
a lot of water yep maybe the animal
welfare conditions aren't the best for
those hands could there be a plant that
if we found it could scramble could have
that casein
where do you start you know we started
just ordering lots of things we randomly
and then we eventually developed a
process where we look at the plank plank
kingdom is a massive data set there are
over three hundred fifty seven thousand
to three hundred fifty seven thousand
species of plants all over the world we
developed a methodology where we source
them we screen them for certain
properties we've organized the data and
if we do our job well enough we can find
certain things that work like that
let's walk us through that process
because that is really fascinating so
how do you pick all these different they
what's what's what are some of the first
things that come to mind is how much
protein they have or how sustainable
they are to grow or how well they would
turn into the thing that you want them
to turn into so we start with we start
with like focusing on what we want at
the highest level so again there's this
awareness the tools used to make a lot
of the products don't work so take the
egg as an example most eggs come from
not-so-good place and not all of them
but most too much land too much water
and then you look at an egg imagine
cracking egg throw it in a pan and then
watch what happens when it's in the pan
it starts to gel as a certain viscosity
how thick or thin it is once it's
scrambled up you eat it it has a certain
texture has a certain flavor release to
it those things that I just mentioned
are functionalities so underlying the
food that we eat is a functional scent
in it for a scrambled egg the functions
that make that include gelation flavor
release texture color right viscosity
and for us the first question is can we
find a plant that does those functions
now we don't need to find a plant that
you know makes a great chicken nugget or
find a plant that makes grace great ice
cream maybe eventually we do we were
just focusing on the egg so we want to
find a plant that does those things and
nothing about those things so initially
it was randomly or a bunch of [ __ ] and
trial you know we ordered lots of things
sometimes we throw things in a pan and
it
just disappear sometimes we throw things
in a pan and it would taste like crap
sometimes we'd throw things in a pan it
would scramble up nicely then fall apart
in a very odd way in your mouth right so
we started to learn though what works
and what doesn't and it turns out that
when you sort of peel the onion
literally back on a plant that you have
molecular characteristics like what is
the molecular weight of the protein what
is the secondary structure of the
protein and then you have functional
characteristics like does it gel and it
turns out fascinatingly so that there's
a relationship between what you see on
the molecular and what is strong a
functional cool and the more that we
tested the more that we identified these
relationships and the more that we test
the more we get smart about where to
look so as opposed to looking everywhere
we're like okay how about we look for
beans that look like this that act like
that okay now let's just test those yeah
and it helped to narrow down the search
base so that you know now when we want
to find something it's still hard but
it's but it's a lot easier than it was
previously
but we source plants from where 51
countries are on the world if you ever
able to make it to headquarters we have
a plant library downstairs run by my my
friend Odie who works with farmers all
across the world to bring those plants
in and then we have an automation lab
where we can screen some of these
molecular characteristics a lot faster
than just human being is going and then
a team of product developers and food
scientists who you know figure out does
this damn thing brown does it gel does
it make really good whatever we're
trying to make yep you've gotten so much
better at that over the years with this
whole up with the operations of that
process you you you've because you've
invested so much time into figuring out
exactly where to start looking how that
how it works
like you said at the molecular of a how
does in gel that is a crucial step as
you continue expanding your line no
really so how many people now is a total
at it's just we have a hundred twenty
people Wow
about 55 or so on there already son
and we have all sorts of different
disciplines we have computational
biologists we have food scientists we
have Michelin star chefs we have PhD
food scientists we have plant
biochemists
we have folks that that are experts in
different areas of process engineering
including bio reactors yes braid dryers
that's where we'll eventually get we'll
eventually get to brewing this and
massive bio reactors and near our homes
and just being able to go and pick up a
little bit of mung bean egg scramble
what well I think I think I think there
are our our approach is that what
matters you know one can use a lot of as
tends to be the case in Silicon Valley
like machine learning is not an
appropriate solution to every problem
nor is automation right though our our
philosophy on this is we're fairly
technology agnostic I just want to solve
the problem and like getting it's always
good to be like what does problem again
okay the toolkit for the current food
system sucks okay why does it suck
because it's not sustainable but gets
unhealthy okay got it
what are you so que soy corn price sugar
can venture on and we'll try to help you
got it
can we build a better toolkit okay got
it working we get that from okay plants
okay that's good animals that's good how
do we do that without causing damage
okay just like this okay let's go
like that's we just kind of use logical
deduction to get back to that and the
plant kingdom is a great source of tools
the animal kingdom is a great source of
source of tools so as long as you don't
confine or slaughter animals yeah so we
can use cells to make meat we can use
plants to scramble neg they're different
processes associated with them yeah but
we just want to get after it and do it
fast yep yep and so the so a hundred and
thirty-five thousand different
distribution outlets right now for point
yes you can Walmart Safeway Kroger 3300
public schools
Wow you're in public schools public
schools yeah five hundred seventy two
universities big football stadiums we're
at the NFL's corporate cafe MBAs
corporate cafes
you're taking over Mexico City with
Walmart so we've been now we've been out
we've been lucky to get out there fast
and so then the vision is that you've
talked about it a couple times and are
we thinking about having this closer to
us in terms of being able to have these
little can I do buying is buying
scramble going to be the way that I
source my egg protein in the future or
will it be something more like a being
able to make it myself at home
where do you kind of see that I think it
I think when you look at you know food
demands growing by 70% between now and
2050 a lot of these big categories meat
eggs dairy baked goods are driving a lot
of the growth the question is how do you
rewire these different categories to
make them a lot better some more people
can eat well yeah
so that becomes a basic right you find
the tools we make products I think we
want to get it on more and more retail
shelves 135,000 points of distribution
sounds good it's very small compared to
what we should where we should be you
know the United States is only 300
million people and we have 7.1 billion
people on the planet right now so we're
failing in that extent we have a lot
more people that we want to reach and
people are not only buying products in a
Walmart but Meru the woman that I
mentioned on Randall Street a Monrovia
Liberia it's selling just power gauri
from a little table she says set up
she's got some mangos on the table she's
got some just powered re that's a retail
location yeah and there are hundreds of
millions literally of retail locations
like that around the world across Mumbai
across sub-saharan Africa across the
middle readiest across South America
yeah we want to be in those places also
you have the food service restaurants
public schools universities all across
the world and the the near term
objective like in the last decade is to
make more of these categories better and
put it in those places yep you know I I
think the idea of decentralizing you
know how one prepares their food I think
that's really exciting I think
next ten years though we're really
focusing on how do we accelerate the
process of getting more of these
categories in a better way and all that
but an important part of it is there are
some big food companies out there some
of the biggest in the world who also
want to do good and make money and if we
can give some of our tools to them to
accelerate their process along this yep
we'll do it yeah that becomes a
harmonious relationship with already
giants that exist and the clients that
they already have around the world no
question so within the Hmong what was
the first ingredient in the scramble was
mung bean bun B it's actually water and
then water than mung bean and then in
the and then this the similar egg is
applied to the cookie as well so it's a
different plant its sorghum which is a
grand so sorghum is a grain that
sometimes is used as animal feed in and
so sorghum so if we tried to take the
plant that's in the cookie and scramble
it it wouldn't work what sorghum does is
it Browns that binds provides a little
bit of aeration not a whole lot of
aeration but browning and binding and a
little flavor release is the key or the
key functionalities that underlies
sorghum so you see here you know you
have a yellow especially in a mole so
fire sorghum a grain that provides those
functionalities among the different
functionalities you notice you have
you're beginning to see sort of the the
beginnings and again we're in the very
very early days of building this tool
kit that we want to build but the very
early days of building a tool kit that I
think makes a lot more sense for where
the world needs to go one more time on
the cookies was the sorghum sorghum that
SOR G H um-hm
where's that sourced from Midwest
Midwest you can find it in Africa
elsewhere Australia but in one source
arm what does it look like what is it
going to grain it's like a brownish a
brown grain grain grown up from the
ground yep yep okay sorghum cool and
okay used sorghum stalks big sorghum
stalks kind of like wheat stalks what
yeah what yeah cooler looking cooler
looking you see you have a very
I love the way that you speak about it
such a visionary way it's almost like
you've been you know you've been at it
for six and a half years but before that
you weren't you know we were just
bonding about how we were both eating
Little Caesars pizzas and breadsticks
and all these cheap foods when we were
younger because that was what was even
accessible to us and all that stuff now
you're now you guys scramble Mayo is all
the stuff that's in that's all the way
into schools as well so now they're all
ready I'm getting them while they're
young and getting them interested in
what this is like
Kimbell must Casas know those learning
gardens as well that's also really
important yeah stuff like that so you
have a very like globalization
perspective you know we want less you
want more sustainability less emissions
you want safer food cleaner food all
this kind of stuff this is very
visionary is your food tastier food as
well yeah I really like the taste of
that among being scrambled cookie was
great to sorghum Mayo was fantastic I
have yet to try the gari really excited
to do so so again it's just so visionary
I love it and I think other people can
to figure out the go and try the just
food it's can I have a bite of that
breakfast sandwich get over here Ronnie
you like do you like the examiner's
right why do you why do you like X what
is it about the a granola whatever have
you ever thought about the underlying
functionalities of an egg when you're
eating it and you may have you ever
thought about like the color the flavor
release gelation all that that's a no
see this is that you the wit the way
he's explaining and a yeah it's how I
previously looked at an egg he's known
about how it looks right like what you
but I had to quickly realize like wait a
second there's like a different lens
here like how do you x-ray it a little
bit Ron what do you think about the mung
bean it's delicious I'm glad you like it
could you could you eat that every day
instead of an egg
I couldn't good so it has yeah has about
the same amount of protein i watch them
as well yeah a little little bit more
fiber but we do think I think I bring us
back to that x-ray because you're going
there and I thought that was really
important before just the is that we
talk about this a lot on the show is the
the way that you view the world the lens
with which you see the world is really
important so if you're looking at an egg
and you're thinking about just the way
that I get to dip some bread into the
yolk and really enjoy the weight fries
and all that kind of stuff we also
forget about the actual process of
sourcing right when you go and just buy
the meat instead of actually going pet a
cow when you actually go and pettite cow
thing life changes a lot because you
realize that that is the being that's
being slaughtered when you go to the
slaughterhouse you just to understand
the whole supply chain of how something
actually gets to you and all that
stuff's really important we've you know
I think in so many ways in this world
it's not just related to food but
suffering cruelty those types of things
really thrive in abstraction and when
you can unpack it when you can really
get very concrete about it like even
think I give an example 2.1 billion
people live in a state of micronutrient
deficiency meaning what nutrients are
they exactly I'm glad you asked that
because that's such an abstract
statement yeah right and the suffering
thrives because it's such an abstract
statement and when you unpack it like
literally what is it mean it literally
means that there's uh there's a young
girl named Abigail who's in the third
grade in Monrovia Liberia who wants to
do a lot of exciting things with her
life who formerly was ripped out of a
brothel where she was held there put
into school to live out her potential
and she's sitting in the second row
today and she has rice in her belly
which means she's not starving which is
really good and she's learning and
that's really good but at that critical
moment when she's as a young person her
brain
doesn't have the nutrients to allow it
to develop and the micronutrient
deficiency concretely means that she is
not receiving enough nutrients to allow
her brain to develop to allow her
reasoning her prefrontal cortex her the
systems in her brain to develop as of
course she should have them developed
and what do we need for them to develop
what are the nutrients nutrients you
need you need a Adan you need iron you
need a rich diet of micronutrients it's
not that complicated right cruel teeth
rise thrives in the abstraction of
eating an egg or eating Mayo right it
you're not one is not thinking when
they're eating mayo about the negative
environmental consequences of how that
product is typically made great of
course or not yeah you know nor should
we in a way I mean you should have a
system that exists in this world that
makes it easy for us to live out who we
are as opposed to a system like the food
system that is almost enabling us to be
separate from who we are yeah the food
system is literally set up right now in
a way where you're actively doing things
that violate your deepest values without
even [ __ ] knowing yeah yes that's
crazy to me that's that is more
fundamentally a system problem than it
is a people problem we all have
responsibility for weed I'm not trying
to like top that out but my perspective
and in doing this with my team back at
2000 Folsom is let's change the system
and let's do it quick
let's try to make this damn thing easy
and we got a you know we gotta use some
x-ray vision on all this stuff to try to
get smart about how to do it better you
had a whole layer of abstraction that's
that's a major problem in the food
systems and the more and more that the
layers of extraction go especially from
shareholders to the people that are
consuming from the farm to the person
that's consuming did the usually the
more issues that we'll have in the
supply chain until it gets there so if
the farm-to-table is closer if the
shareholders align their values and more
with
I'm sustainability I think that will be
a healthier world
you mentioned micronutrient deficiency
this is a big deal because somebody that
is that when someone's brain is forming
into the world in order for them to be
able to have a developed cognition down
the line especially when they're by the
time they're 12 and 18 and 25 and
they're trying to do something into the
world if we allow that to happen to
millions of people in the world that
that creates a massive problem for us
and that should be something that we
immediately try and address think about
think about all that innovation think
about even if we just thought it think
about this problem as if all we are is
selfish for a second you got 2.1 billion
people out there who cannot realize
their full potential
whose brain literally will not be
working properly two point 1 billion
people many of whom could be inventing
the things that make our lives better
2.1 billion people who could be helping
our economies improve 2.1 billion people
that could be peacemakers of the future
and you know that that is that is
patently unfair this is like 1 in every
3 almost people this is that's a lot of
people you know and I think you know one
thing that wow I think it's important
for for folks um for folks that are that
are that are listening to us right now
that are watching us that the food
system when we talk about it in San
Francisco when we talk about the food
system in New York City people's brains
just stay in the United States they
think about farming in the u.s. they
think about you know Whole Foods in the
US this is where our brains naturally go
but you know the food system is is most
painful to the 3 billion people who are
living under $8 a day right now not to
me and you the food stuff is certainly
painful at us and we that did
innovations that are happening in
Silicon Valley
neglecting the billions of people that
live under 87 for $1 a day is unjust I
think it's stupid
also yeah bookies are a lot of exciting
business models to to reach down and
allow people to to do what they want in
their lives to empower themselves and we
get really we get really excited about
that yeah you studied a globalization a
lot and I mean you're you have a very
good solid understanding of kind of
what's going on in Silicon Valley and
how it was a I think you'll agree with
me on this but the life being a roll of
the dice in terms of where you're born
into the world and so because of that it
almost makes it if you do treat the
world as your brothers and sisters as
the rest of the planet then at every
moment of life thinking about what's
going on in other parts of the world it
it almost becomes our obligation being
born into a place that makes it easier
for us to impact those places to help
them receive the nutrients they need for
their brains to grow for the for us to
help them with disease and help them
with poverty and all these other things
it almost becomes an obligation for us
and I or ties that and to do that
because we would also want that if we
were in their shoes seeing other places
in the world thrive so well especially
you know people think a false choice
exists that to to reach out and have an
impact like that it needs to be a
nonprofit that you're donating to you
know or a United Nations agency that
you're working with but the reality is
there there are a lot of entrepreneurs
out there that could start companies
they're having an impact and not just
not just for folks under the poverty
line outside the US many folks said I
was raised with in Alabama live under
the poverty line made many on food
stamps today many people in rural West
Virginia and Western Kentucky Eastern
Kentucky they're just they're really
exciting food businesses that one can
build that doesn't just focus on serving
people that make over one hundred fifty
thousand dollars at their local Whole
Foods you know yeah and that's yeah
that's exciting it forces the spring I
think of creativity and you know it's
it's it's also the fair thing to do
yep let's walk you down a couple of our
simulation ask questions as we talk
about globalization as we talk about
things like a couple people eight people
having concentrated as much wealth as
the bottom four billion people no talk
to talk to us about kind of what your
thoughts are about wealth inequality how
do we what do we do about it hmm well I
think I think one thing that we can do
about it is thinking about the the vast
majority of folks that do live under $8
a day that do live in societies in the
US where you're not living under $8 a
day but they're still massive inequality
and growing up our median family income
was like in the mid 20 thousands I think
the most important thing I think to do
is to give people access to tools like
knowledge tools tools everything from
food that they otherwise can have access
to to the ability to have access to
technologies enable you to empower
yourself to access to teachers that
allow you to learn better to access to
communities that can help nurture and
mentor you these are all tools that I
think shape and never guarantee but
nonetheless they do increase the
probability that you can realize your
full potential tools that when you're in
a classroom you're not just eating rice
it's the void of any micronutrients
right and I think tools are across the
spectrum you have tools of technology
you have tools of food you have tools of
community I think there's a toolkit that
simply increases the probability that
one can realize their full potential
let's talk about that then what would
you prescribe as the toolkit for maybe a
parent to deliver their child as they
are growing up what would be your ideal
tool kit for the kids born around the
world well I mean it'd probably be so
let's just let's go back to that girl
Abigail in the third grade Monrovia
Liberia so she would start she'd have a
really good teacher and teachers she'd
have teachers that are smart that show
up on time that push her she'd have food
that allows her brain to fully develop
she would have acts
to technologies so she could read so she
could learn so she could search so she
could code in the way that she wants to
she would have access as she has ideas
to capital whether that's in the form of
micro loans or in the form of you know
incubators or even venture capital she
would have a government that allows her
to do things freely speak freely vote
freely be freely as opposed to
suffocating her mind in her body with
[ __ ] that's probably where I'd start
that's great and I think you need you
know I think it's a combination of
companies trying to do the right thing
and and society's realizing that they
shouldn't always listen to leaders that
throw a lot of [ __ ] at them that
[ __ ] they should listen to pragmatic
thoughtful rational leaders who believe
in evidence-based thinking in a reason
and believe in the human spirit that
don't talk in ways that are alienating
who can go to McDowell County West
Virginia and me tutor and realize that
there's nothing intrinsically wrong at
all with that person right what the
problem is is the system that that
person is living in full of fake news
full of mistrust in full of often you
know people who come off as being elite
who can't understand the world that
she's living in yeah that sucks we fix
it we yeah we're we're on our way we're
on our way all these beautiful minds you
know you and food and we have a lot of
great people working in news a lot of
great people working in education them
not only happy you paint about that
though that toolkit I'm glad to bring
tools as a major touch point in this in
this point because you know I think the
part of my like interest in like the
world you don't if my you know if my if
I need to if my house gets hit by a you
know a tornado or something there are
tools to rebuild a house there are tools
to make yourself your your lunch or your
dinner there are tools to fix your car
and to me there's an impound
- these when I think of what the word
tool it like implicit in it is not just
we're giving you it for free there's a
little bit of work behind it you know
you got to still do something with the
tool it's always in the product correct
you know just because you know I'm in a
classroom and I have a really good
teacher and that's a tool that I didn't
have before I better take advantage of
that really good teacher just because I
have access to technologies does you
know doesn't mean that I'm gonna use
them but it does mean that it's giving
me an opportunity just because I have
access to better food doesn't
necessarily mean I'm gonna choose better
food maybe I still choose that Little
Caesars Pizza that I eat back in the day
but at least you're giving someone the
opportunity to be able to assess it and
either they add a Dacian to use the tool
yeah and to me that's where like getting
back to to eating well that education
eating well these should be basic rights
yep you know and again you don't always
have to exercise the basic right but if
you want to you sure can
yep what do you what's one thing that
you believe to be true that nobody else
believes to be true I believe that and a
I'll give you two things I think one is
in a time period that is much much
shorter than people realize that we can
wake up and this food system problem can
be licked I think people look at the
food system and it rightfully so comes
off as incredibly daunting it's complex
it's frustrating politics and culture I
mean it's it's [ __ ] us all true but
again if you cut through all that
[ __ ]
here's they got what's going on the
tools are [ __ ] up to make our food we
need better tools let's find those
[ __ ] tools
let's make better categories let's
empower other big companies to be able
to do it and let's go fast and let's do
it and let's make sure poor people are
eating along the way and at a time I
think that's much shorter than people
realize not in the way that is
you know filled with hyperbole not in a
way that is overly optimistic in a way
that's just looking at the physics and
breaking it down I think you can be
licked a lot a lot faster than people
think probably the second thing is I
think you know the vast majority of
people in the world look at people who
are living under you know three four
dollars a day and naturally assume I
will give my money away to them I will
support save the children I will support
the United Nations I will pray for them
all good things by the way but I think
the way you help the poorest among us is
to say let me start a company to give
them better tools mm-hmm and there is a
lot of money to be made and there's a
lot of good I think more good to be done
through that approach definitely and it
it requires I think kind of just a shift
away from you're a victim to if you only
had you know that that hand up you could
do everything that you want your life
and that ends up you know helping me and
in the company too I think there's a lot
there's a lot of power and energy in
that idea yeah in in always and forever
building companies that can solve
problems in the world for me is way more
impactful than purchasing a watch or a
bow or whatever and I hope that that
really gets to people over time as we
keep talking about this thing and it's
so clickable to wealth inequality as
well so how about do you think we're
alone in the cosmos definitely not I
think I think there's a very very high
probability somewhere above 99% that
we're not alone and that's simply by if
you look at the size of the universe
it's you know this little planet is a
tiny speck of sand on all the world's
beaches and that's under estimating how
big the universe is relative to us the
idea that the set of tools that would be
available on our planet is not on
another planet or even in other species
requires an entirely different kind of
set of elements and a life support
system
you really got to stretch to believe
that I think you've really got to be
arrogant and self-possessed and human
obsessed to think that were the only
ones around here and then do you think
we're in a computer simulation
unlikely
I hope or not I think it's unlikely but
it's difficult to it's difficult to
analyze that rational yeah but I think I
think more likely not this is real life
and and we got a we got to take
advantage of the few seconds that we
have in this real life mm-hmm
now would you what would you say is the
most beautiful thing in the world I
think the most beautiful thing in the
world is a really good question
I think the most beautiful thing in the
world is the peaceful act of simply
being who we are and I think that
applies equally to human beings who I
think at our core want to be
compassionate want to care about each
other what a good life for their family
want to eat well as it does to a
mountain gorillas and Uganda who simply
wants to be with you know his troop and
exist in that way to a clownfish in a
sea anenome we don't need to create
these false constructions of who we are
and I think there's beauty and just a
simplicity of being who we are and we
have systems whether it's in a food
system and energy system a political
system a a transportation system that
makes it really challenging for us for a
clownfish and a sea anenome for a lion
on a Savannah to a dog to a mountain
gorilla simply to be who we are
yeah and I think I think the most
beautiful thing is just being who we are
and I think the systems that we build in
this world should be supportive of that
exactly we got to add more supportive
systems to help us be who we are and
strip out the ones that are not helping
us be who we are that's it know how to
have global conversation about what
those are listen the Pacific Garbage
Patch and the agriculture runoff in
oceans that that destroys ocean systems
the polarization cognitive bias all of
this to me
moves us further and further away from a
natural state of being being you know
you talk to young young kids you have to
wire in racism to a young child you have
to wire in through a lack of compassion
for animals you need a wire in a lack of
care or wire in fear yeah
intrinsically most people want to do the
right thing intrinsically you know a
wolf wants to roam freely without being
shot you know by sniper and I think
figuring out a way to just the the earth
and its systems are designed so
beautifully let's not [ __ ] it up do you
think there is a meaning or a purpose to
life you know if there's if there's any
meaning and purpose I think it's trying
to fight every day to retain that and
that the technologies that are popping
up all around us I think don't need to
it's not about creating an alternate
reality that is different than who we
are let's let's let's figure out a way
to get back to that and I think if there
is any meaning and purpose I think it's
trying to figure out as fast as we can
to to to be who we are to act in
accordance with basic values that that
we all share and that's what I want us
to always fight for yep I love when
people sit in that chair and they pass
along some very strong wisdom and that's
why we have you on we have you on
because you are driven you're making
tremendous impact in the food and health
and nutrition of other people everything
from micronutrient deficiency across the
world to 2.1 billion people all the way
to the woman that's selling power Gauri
mama Ruth Ruth mom Ruth or Randall she's
uh she's slinging the power Gauri and
mangoes - don't forget about mango she
she's selling the [ __ ] out of those
mangoes a hundred and thirty-five
thousand places that you can get just so
Walmart Whole Foods Kroger stop by the
stores go give it a go give it a shot
just for all dot-com as well what is our
approximation on the chicken breast time
we're gonna we're gonna be said we're
pushing our goal before the end of the
year is to get out the first meat
product that didn't require the
confinement or the killing of an animal
today the idea of eating animals
or eating meat necessarily means that an
animal was there and then not because we
can find and kill the animal I think in
the future we'll be able to eat all the
meat we want yep without killing and
confining and our goals for the end of
the year to do that first to have a
breast in the store - by the end of the
year you know either either chicken beef
pork some some one of those products
could be in the form of chicken nugget
yeah sausage or ground we're still we're
still end of the year by the end of the
usos know you already have all the
distribution which is really crucial now
an add additional products in and hope
that they go well maybe definitely makes
a little bit easier now we got here we
got we got a crew back there at 2000
Folsom that bus or us every day who well
they come in to work every day sure but
they they've really built they built an
amazing mission and it's cool to do this
every day with 120 amazing people that
work with you alongside you to actually
make this dream come true
we just talked to Josh Kaufman about
this he and I were just chatting about
it but even though you represent the
company as a CEO and the founder it's
really the people that are doing
everything from the the biology all the
way to the research that's required as
well as the people that even clean the
office afterward it's every everybody
like that is the reason why I got was
before I left here I mean I where I was
I kind of sit in the middle now and we
had operations as to my left we're
dealing with procurement we're ensuring
that orders get there on time and in
full zach is doing with transportation
you got Caroline I see all the purchase
orders emails coming out she's making
sure that the POS are delivered on time
yeah got robbed and run around with
headphones and cleaned up stuff to make
sure everything's organized you got
Arthur a head of workplace it's helping
to manage the entire operations we got
all sorts of construction projects that
are happening you got my finance team a
res my co VP my Beverly my VP of Finance
you're making sure that we have systems
and processes in our gross margin it's
expanding you got sitting behind me you
got product management Madu who makes
sure that I don't just come home after
talking to
really smart people and say I want to
launch this this and this and this she
keeps us organized to make sure that we
have a process for doing it the right
way further behind me you got the entire
R&D team a 50-plus Hmong and my
computational biology team viv who leads
a discovery in plant biochemistry got
ching-yan automation who's making sure
the robots are doing what they need then
you got product development over there
that's taking these tools led by Chris
Jones and one of the early people that
made this place what it what it
continues to be then you got the design
mezzanine where you got Jordan viola who
designs all the stuff Eric who drives
marketing sherry who's taking pictures
putting it on social media you got Mike
and Vlad and analytical you got Andrew
and comm that's making sure that we're
telling the right stories for the right
people got some dogs down stairs you
know takes a village to do this damn
yeah are you going through your mind a
whole map of that go that was awesome I
probably I probably probably missed like
four different four different pieces of
it but it's weird it's um it's it's hard
to it's hard not to be enormous ly
grateful for those guys yes and we
celebrate entrepreneurship on the show
all the time and this is a great example
of how it takes a village to bring this
to fruition over time you got the pilot
plant downstairs you got you got Dre and
Hans in the team I got in early this
morning and I saw them busting their ass
on a decanting centrifuge and a spray
dryer I mean it goes on and on and for
next time we'll talk about what Adi
canning I don't know what that was
couple years ago yeah and that's what
I'm saying it's nuts that you ought Oded
acted you you know you pull you pulled
this self-learning into your own life
and then you want to kept talking a
brilliant people and building this out
into the world so go check out the
products the just products out the
stores um thank you everyone for tuning
in if you had a good time give us a like
comment subscribe if you found this
content useful share it with other
people let's get more people talking
about clean food the importance of this
across the world immersing ourselves in
other people's shoes across the world
and the importance of what it would be
like to be them if it's just a roll of
dye then maybe we should be focusing a
lot of our time on helping uplift them
and eradicate suffering so Thank You
Josh thank you so much for your time
plus fun washer Thank You Tosh love
thank you thanks everyone
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]